Freunde der prähistorischen Unterhaltung:
"Jurassic World" ist zurück.
Ich freue mich
auf den neuen Film.
Denn die Dinos werden immer größer,
bissiger und gefährlicher.
*Brüllen*
In der Gentechnik in der realen Welt
hat sich auch viel getan.
Vor 2 Jahren
gab es sogar eine echte Sensation.
Da fanden Forscher Dino-DNA.
Sind wir jetzt nah dran,
einen Mega-Saurier zu erzeugen?
*Fauchen*
Das ist die Voraussetzung
für die Park-Attraktionen.
Aber weil der 1. Teil
fast 30 Jahre zurückliegt,
frischen uns die Film-Experten
mal die Erinnerungen auf.
Alpha, wie ist es damals
eigentlich abgelaufen?
Im 1. "Jurassic-Park"
plant ein steinreicher Unternehmer
einen riesigen Vergnügungspark.
Er scheut keine Kosten,
um Saurier auferstehen zu lassen.
(wiederholend)
"Ich habe keine Kosten gescheut."
Wie das geht, dafür liefert er
die wissenschaftliche Erklärung.
Seine Forscher haben 100 Millionen
Jahre alte Mücken gefunden.
Diese Mücken haben sich
von Dinosaurier-Blut ernährt.
Danach wurden sie
in Bernstein eingeschlossen.
Damit sind sie
perfekt erhalten geblieben.
Mit "modernsten Methoden"
kann man das Mückenblut entnehmen.
Damit haben sie zugleich
auch Saurier-DNS.
Überwältigend, John.
Darüber wurde im Laufe der Zeit
viel diskutiert.
Aber wir checken jetzt mal
den letzten Stand der Technik.
Wie plausibel ist das heute?
Das frage ich
die Gen-Expertin Verena Laupert.
Verena ist Bioinformatikerin.
Sie nutzt "Künstliche Intelligenz",
um große Datensätze auszuwerten.
Ihr Lieblings-Dino
ist der Triceratops.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Schön, dass ich hier sein darf.
2020 schlug mein Jurassic-Herz höher:
Da kam diese Papier hier heraus.
Da steht, ein internationales
Forschungsteam fand Dino-DNA.
Das war eine Sensation.
Der Hintergrund ist, dass in Montana
vor 75 Millionen Jahren
Entenschnabel-Dinosaurier gelebt.
Ich sehe, dass auf deinem T-Shirt
ein Entenschnabel-Dino drauf ist.
Ja, das ist ein witziger Name.
Das Forschungsteam hat Knochen
von diesen Sauriern gefunden
und diese untersucht.
Die haben nicht nur Zellen gefunden,
die man noch verwerten konnte,
sondern auch Zellkerne.
Und in einigen Zellkernen
sieht man dunkle faserige Gebilde.
Und die sahen aus wie DNA.
Dann haben sie es eingefärbt
und es leuchten gesehen.
Es war tatsächlich DNA.
Das ist richtig irre,
weil die Funde so alt sind.
Was ist das Problem?
DNA geht schnell kaputt.
Genau, die DNA
hat eine Halbwertzeit.
Wenn der Körper stirbt,
dann stirbt auch die Zelle.
Da kommen Enzyme,
das sind kleine Peptide.
Die zerschneiden die DNA.
Dann kommen Mikroorganismen
und fressen diese Stücke auf.
Was dann noch übrig ist,
unterliegt dem natürlichen Zerfall.
Das hängt davon ab,
wie der PH-Wert, der Sauerstoff-
und Wasser-Gehalt der Umgebung ist.
Aber so altes Material
ist nicht mehr zu gebrauchen.
Wenn zu wenig DNA da ist,
dann kann man nicht mehr zuordnen,
zu welchem Tier das mal gehört hat.
Auch Analysen kann man nicht machen,
klar.
Im 1. Teil sehen wir
das Hantieren mit dem Bernstein.
John Hammond trägt ihn mit Mücke drin
prominent auf seinem Stock.
Ist Bernstein gut zum Konservieren?
Bernstein ist in 1. Linie gut,
um Schmuckstücke herzustellen.
Zum Konservieren von DNA
ist es weniger gut geeignet.
Denn Bernstein
enthält ziemlich viel Wasser.
Und Wasser
begünstigt den Zerfall von DNA.
Was wäre besser geeignet?
Ein prominentes Beispiel
ist Permafrost.
Die Funde,
die im ewigen Eis gemacht werden.
Verkalkungen sind gut geeignet
und alles, was mumifiziert ist.
Nehmen wir mal an,
wir haben gute Bedingungen.
Wie lange hält sich eine DNA?
Das ist ein ganzes
Forschungs-Spektrum.
Der bekannteste Forscher darin
ist Morton Allentoft.
Dessen Team aus Dänemark
hat sich der Frage angenähert.
Die haben 8.000 Jahre alte Knochen
untersucht.
Sie fanden heraus, die DNA hat
eine Halbwertzeit von 521 Jahren.
Aber was heißt das?
In 521 Jahren zerfallen die Hälfte
der Verbindungen der DNA-Buchstaben.
In weiteren 521 Jahren
zerfällt wieder die Hälfte usw.
Sie haben das hochgerechnet
und sind zu dem Schluss gekommen,
dass selbst bei guten Bedingungen
von -5°C
DNA eigentlich
nur 6,8 Millionen Jahre überlebt.
Aber bei dem Fund in Montana
hat es ja trotzdem geklappt.
Daher Schritt 1 zum Mega-Saurier:
DNA zu finden, ist nicht unmöglich.
DNA zerfällt also ziemlich schnell.
Auch der Sensations-Fund aus Montana
bestand nur aus Fragmenten.
Bevor wir schauen, ob das ausreicht,
um daraus einen Saurier zu machen,
schauen wir in die Film-Welt
und fragen, wie es dort war.
Wie sind die von der DNA
aus der Mücke zum Embryo gekommen?
Auch in "Jurassic-Park" finden
die Forscher nur DNA-Fragmente.
Mit Super-Computern
und Gen-Sequenzierern
die man offenbar nur mit verrückten
Handschuhen bedienen kann,
schaffen sie es,
die komplette DNS aufzuschlüsseln.
und das, was fehlt, die Lücke,
sichtbar zu machen.
Dann legen sie einen DNS-Strang
von einem Frosch daneben
und füllen die fehlenden DNS-Stellen
mit den Schnipseln der Amphibien.
Der so fertiggebaute
komplette DNS-Strang
wird in unbefruchtete
Emu- oder Straußeneier gesetzt.
Und aus diesen Eiern schlüpfen dann
kleine süße Saurier-Babys.
Im Film haben sie also auch
nur DNA-Fragmente.
Lässt sich damit
überhaupt etwas anfangen?
Wir haben nur Fragmente
und nicht das gesamte Erbgut.
Und es ist wie ein Puzzle.
Wir wissen nicht, wie das
ursprüngliche Puzzle aussieht.
Wir kennen nicht alle Teile.
Und wir wissen auch nicht,
wie viele Teile fehlen: 3 oder 300.
Das muss simuliert werden.
Man kann von den nächsten Verwandten
das Puzzle-Spiel nehmen
und es damit vervollständigen.
Das würde schon funktionieren.
Wenn wir also Frosch-DNA nehmen,
ist das nicht besonders clever.
Prinzipiell schon.
Das Krokodil wäre die bessere Wahl.
Oder auch der Vogel.
Das wären die nächsten Verwandten.
Das kann man im Prinzip
auch schon machen.
Zum Vergleich:
Wir sind auch zu 50% Banane.
Man könnte also aus der Banane
Puzzle-Teile holen.
Unsere nächsten Verwandten
sind die Schimpansen oder Bonobo.
Da gibt es 99% DNA-Übereinstimmung.
Das heißt im Umkehrschluss auch,
dass das 1% zu sehr großen
Unterschieden führen kann.
Ja, Wahnsinn, was 1% für
unterschiedliche Auswirkungen hat.
Manchmal kennen wir
die Auswirkungen noch gar nicht.
Klar ist, wir werden keinen Dino
1:1 so herstellen können.
Aber das DNA-Material von anderen
aufzunehmen, ist nicht dumm.
Nein, das ist nicht
aus der Luft gegriffen.
Da müssen wir erst tiefer einsteigen
in die genetische Materie.
Da müssen wir
in die Trickkiste greifen.
Wir müssen
die CRISPR-Technologie begreifen.
Davon hat man schon gehört
in letzter Zeit.
Das ist die "Genschere", mit der man
die DNA zerschneiden kann.
Ja, herausnehmen oder auch
Neues einfügen, darum geht es ja.
Einer der Vorreiter
ist dabei George Church.
Er hat sich damit beschäftigt
und die Methode eingeführt.
Heute ist das Standard
in einem Gen-Labor.
Der hat sich allerdings nicht
für Dinos interessiert.
Sein Herz schlägt für Mammuts.
Der hat sich
Abschnitte der Mammut-DNA genommen.
Die sind ja auch
seit einer Weile ausgestorben.
Er hat sich 14 Abschnitte der DNA
mit speziellen Eigenschaften
vorgenommen.
Mammuts haben längere Haare
und kleinere Ohren als Elefanten.
Das sind Eigenschaften, die für
das Überleben im Eis sinnvoll sind.
Er nahm die 14 Gene und fügte sie
in asiatische Elefanten ein.
Mit der CRISPR-Methode.
Hat das funktioniert?
Ja und nein:
Im Labor hat es gut funktioniert.
Das Ziel ist aber,
dass Mammuts wieder auferstehen.
und über den Permafrostboden laufen.
Wird spannend, wann wir die ersten
lebenden Exemplare zu sehen bekommen.
Welche ausgestorbenen Tiere
findet ihr cool?
Schreibt mir in die Kommentare,
welche ihr gern wiedersehen würdet.
(erstaunt) Das ist ein Dinosaurier.
Wenn das bei Mammuts funktioniert,
müsste das auch bei Sauriern gehen.
Prinzipiell hast du recht.
Es gibt ein Problem: Mammuts sind
vor ca. 4.000 Jahren ausgestorben,
Dinos vor ca. 65 Mio. Jahren.
Das führt zu 2 Effekten:
1. Bei Mammuts haben wir
die nächsten Verwandten: Elefanten.
Die DNA stimmt zu 99% überein.
Das können wir gut nutzen
zum Puzzeln.
Beim Dino sieht das anderes aus.
Da haben wir zwar Verwandte
wie Krokodile oder Vögel.
Da stimmt die DNA
nicht mehr so stark überein.
Das 2. Problem: Die DNA
ist leider schon sehr zerstückelt.
Und damit nicht mehr komplett.
Aber vielleicht
brauchen wir die DNA auch gar nicht.
Dinos auferstehen lassen ohne DNA?
Ja, da müssen wir
ein wenig fantasievoll sein.
Aber wir denken schon
über "umgedrehte Evolution" nach.
(zögerlich)
Okay, klingt ganz einfach.
Es ist zumindest nicht unmöglich.
Das Interessante an der Evolution
ist nämlich,
dass die Gen-Informationen nicht weg
sind, sondern nur deaktiviert sind.
Beispiel: Alle Embryonen
haben so ein Schwänzchen.
Das verschwindet dann beim Menschen.
Wenn man nun wüsste, welches Gen
dafür verantwortlich ist,
könnte man das wieder aktivieren.
Und dann könnten wir wieder
mit einem Schwänzchen herumlaufen.
Vielleicht unpraktisch,
aber theoretisch machbar.
Da könnte man mit der Re-Aktivierung
aus Vögeln Dinos machen?
Ja, zumindest könnten wir
bestimmte Eigenschaften zurückholen.
Schauen wir uns Hühner an.
Die sind die nächsten Verwandten
von Dinosauriern.
Man kann sich das heute
kaum mehr vorstellen.
Matthew Harris schaute sich mal
einen mutierten Hühner-Embryo an.
Er fand kleine Ansätze von Zähnen.
Die haben normalerweise
keine Zähne.
Daran sieht man, dass in Hühnern
noch bestimmte Eigenschafen stecken.
die wir vom Saurier kennen.
Also ist Dino-DNA im Huhn vorhanden.
Anderes Beispiel: der Velociraptor.
Der hat 3 Klauen.
Vergleichen wir das wieder
mit den Hühner-Embryos:
Da sehen wir die Kralle auch.
Die entwickeln sich zwar zu Flügeln.
Aber wir sehen die Ähnlichkeit.
Die Entwicklung zum Fliegen hin,
ist wieder ein natürlicher Prozess.
Gibt es ein Beispiel, wo man gezielt
ein Gen reaktiviert hat?
Die Forschung ist dran.
Bleiben wir bei den Hühnern.
Die haben unterentwickelte Waden.
Jetzt wurde das Gen dafür
deaktiviert.
Daraufhin haben sich die Waden
stark weiterentwickelt.
Die muten jetzt schon richtig
prähistorisch an.
Wenn wir das Entwicklungsprogramm
von Genen besser verstehen,
können wir gezielt
Veränderungen vornehmen.
Dann wird zwar aus dem Huhn
kein 10 m großes Monster,
aber ein Vogel mit kräftigen Beinen,
langen Klauen und scharfen Zähnen.
Jetzt haben wir
über die CRISPR-Technik gesprochen.
Die spielt auch in den neueren Filmen
eine Rolle.
Zum Beispiel beim Designen
und Züchten des Indominus Rex.
Der ist ja die geplante Attraktion
in "Jurassic World".
Und er hat tolle Eigenschaften.
Welche, erzählt uns Alpha.
Indominus Rex sollte der krasseste
Dinosaurier überhaupt werden.
16 m lang, 5,5 m hoch
und natürlich Fleischfresser.
Seine DNS ist eine Kombination
aus verschiedenen Sauriern,
Tintenfischen und Baumfröschen.
Das macht Indominus Rex
nicht nur aggressiv und intelligent,
wie ein Hannibal Lecter mit Tollwut,
er kann auch seine Farbe ändern
und seine Wärme regulieren.
Und genau das ermöglicht ihm
den Ausbruch aus einem Beton-Gehege.
*Brüllen*
Ein krasses Vieh!
Wenn wir solche Methoden brauchen,
um Saurier aufstehen zu lassen,
dann ist doch das Einbeziehen neuer
Eigenschaften kein Problem, oder?
Einfach hin- und herwürfeln ...
Innerhalb einer Species
ist das relativ einfach.
Da kennen wir
verschiedene Funktionsweisen.
Da können wir mit CRISPR Gene
rausschneiden und deaktivieren.
Und auch neue Stücke einsetzen.
Das wurde auch schon gemacht.
So haben wir heute Schweine,
die gegen Schweinepest immun sind.
Oder Kühe,
die allergenfreie Milch liefern.
Das klingt krass und gruselig.
Wie genau hat man das gemacht?
Hier müssen wir
etwas in die Tiefe gehen.
Die Gen-Schere besteht aus 2 Teilen.
Die 1. ist die Guide-RNA.
Das ist die leitende RNA.
Sie ist komplementär zur Ziel-DNA,
sucht diese und dockt da an.
Dann kommt das Protein Cas9
ins Spiel.
Das ist die Schere.
Und wenn wir wissen wo,
schneidet das Cas9 die RNA ab.
Und das auf Zellebene.
Irre, dass das geht.
Aber im Organismus
sind Billionen von Zellen.
Das kann man ja nicht
mit jeder Zelle einzeln machen.
Da hast du recht,
das ist unmöglich.
Was man aber gemacht hat
bei den genannten Beispielen, ist:
Man hat das Cas9 in einem frühen
embryonalen Stadium eingefügt.
Dadurch hat es sich
in jeder Zelle vermehrt
und ist in jeder Zelle vorhanden.
Und die Guide-RNA
hat man später dazugegeben.
Dadurch hat es sich mitentwickelt
und das Tier verändert.
Man hat dann die Veränderung in
jeder Zelle des erwachsenen Tiers.
Das klingt
nach unendlichen Möglichkeiten
rein technisch.
Die ethische Debatte daran
klammern wir jetzt erst mal aus.
Deswegen könnt ihr mal sagen,
was würdet ihr den Tieren
dran- oder wegprogrammieren.
Ich finde ja bestimmte Immunitäten
gegen Krankheiten sehr sinnvoll.
Wenn euch etwas dazu einfällt,
lasst eure Kommentare dazu da.
Na, mein Baby.
Wir müssen also wissen,
welcher DNA-Schnipsel wo hingehört.
welches Genom wofür zuständig ist.
Genau, aber das wissen wir
gar nicht so genau.
Vom menschlichen Genom kennen wir
zwar die Buchstabenabfolge.
Wir kennen das ganze Buch der DNA,
theoretisch.
Aber wir wissen nur von 1-2%,
welche Funktion sie haben.
Der Rest bleibt zu erforschen.
Da ist also noch
eine Menge zu tun.
Und es wird sicher komplizierter,
wenn es komplexe Eigenschaften geht.
Denn den Indominus Rex wollen wir
nicht nur aggressiv haben,
der soll als gefährlicher Jäger
ja auch noch schlau sein.
Was im Film nicht nur gut ausgeht.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein ausgelagertes Hirn.
Intelligenz ist ein gutes Beispiel
für eine komplexe Eigenschaft.
Sie ist nicht nur erblich bedingt.
Da spielen soziale Faktoren
auch eine große Rolle.
Zum 2. ist das Feature Intelligenz
nicht nur auf einem Gen zu finden,
sondern auf vielen.
Die kennen wir auch noch nicht alle.
Insofern ist es schwierig,
mit der Gen-Schere anzusetzen,
wenn wir nicht wissen,
wo wir schneiden sollen.
Wir müssen diese Zusammenhänge
ja für alle Tierarten begreifen.
wenn wir die in den Indominus Rex
hineinbringen wollen.
Wenn ein neuer Dino die Farbe ändern
oder die Wärme regulieren soll,
muss man die Gene kennen.
Und man muss die Funktionen kennen,
die die Features haben.
Selbst wenn wir das alles wissen,
wird es schwierig bleiben,
das wild zusammenzumischen.
Denn wir verstehen bis heute
die Wechselwirkungen nicht.
Wenn die Puzzle-Teile
einfach nicht zusammenpassen,
können wir sie
auch nicht zusammenfügen.
Am Ende kommt etwas heraus,
das nicht überlebensfähig ist,
oder irgendwelche Krankheiten hat.
In Teil 2 sind sie dann so verrückt,
dass sie den Indoraptor züchten.
Es wird einfach immer komplexer
und komplizierter.
Und wenn wir das zusammenfassen,
können wir sagen:
Die Gentechnik der letzten Jahrzehnte
ist enorm fortgeschritten.
Wir können Eigenschaften von Tieren
verändern und beeinflussen.
Aber wir können keine Dinos designen,
geschweige denn einen Indominus Rex.
Bis wir da angekommen sind,
einen solchen Saurier zu erzeugen,
muss noch geforscht werden.
Wir müssen uns damit abfinden,
Dinos nur im Kino zu sehen.
Ich habe nichts dagegen,
denn so muss ich nicht davonlaufen.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Freut ihr euch auf Teil 3?
Schreibt uns das in die Kommentare.
Ich möchte mich noch bedanken
bei Alpha.
Wenn ihr Zeit habt, flitzt rüber
zu denen und lasst Liebe von uns da.
Vergesst bitte nicht ...,
... diesen Kanal zu abonnieren.
Und?
Die Glocke zu drücken.
Ich freue mich drauf.
Verena, danke!
Hühner,
die allergenfreie Milch liefern.
Ach so, haha.
Wir müssen von allen Tieren,
die wir einbringen, ...
Von Tintenfröschen ...
UT: MDR 2022